there's a bear chasing me
oh
okay
hey you have to leave now you have to
leave now you're supposed to leave
goodbye
what is up everyone mad luigi here and
today i want to preach the good news of
the seamless co-op mod for eldon ring if
you don't know recently a mod called
seamless co-op was released in beta on
nexus mods it allows players to engage
in co-op in elden ring without the
normal limitations of summoning and
re-summoning this mod lets you join your
friend's game and play continuously
until you choose to leave dying doesn't
disconnect you killing the area boss
doesn't disconnect you and you can even
fast travel all together the mod is easy
to install and essentially works by
having you play in offline mode and
disabling anti-cheat once downloaded and
running the mod allows players to
connect directly to each other
peer-to-peer it doesn't use fromsoft
servers so there should be minimal
possibility of getting banned or
penalized by fromsoft but of course
don't solely take my word for it and
read for yourself what the mod does on
its download page to make sure that you
are okay with using it and to make sure
that you're using it correctly to avoid
penalty but also allow me to say this
mod is an amazing amount of fun the
normal co-op of from software games
achieves a certain feeling but it's
totally different to being able to
continually progress through the game
with friends in a seamless fashion and
yes each player can progress normally
with the mod each player can upgrade
weapons level up stats and collect loot
all from the same world if you've played
other instanced rpgs with a more
integrated co-op system this is pretty
similar not to mention that the mod is
made impressively well it was only just
released in beta but for a mod of this
kind where i would expect a whole host
of desync issues i was amazed by how
well everything flowed and by the
quality of the mod aspects from new
items to activate the new co-op mode to
integrated animations such as the one to
turn pvp on and here we see another
radical change that this mod brings the
ability to continually pvp with your
friends friendly fire can be turned on
or off through a new item and with the
feature you can battle your friends
without needing to re-summon them or
simply fight through the game world with
realistic damage to each other turned on
demanding that you play carefully so as
to not kill each other while you fight
the monsters of the lands between and i
can't tell you how refreshing it is to
be able to play the game with friends
and not have to fret with constant
re-summoning and switching between
worlds i can only speak for myself but
the standard way of multiplayer
implementation in these games while
definitely achieving its own kind of
experience can get pretty exhausting
when i want to just play continuously
with my friends for those of you who
might not have heard the story the
inspiration for the style of multiplayer
in fromsoft games came from a personal
event in game director hidetaka
miyazaki's life according to a eurogamer
article released in the wake of demon
souls the drop dropout co-op style was
inspired by a time when miyazaki and
some others got their cars stuck on a
snowy hill some strangers in the car
behind him helped pushed his car to get
it unstuck and going again as miyazaki
tells it i couldn't stop the car to say
thanks to the people who gave me a shove
i'd have just got stuck again if i'd
stopped on the way back home i wondered
whether the last person in the line had
made it home and thought that i would
probably never meet the people who had
helped me i thought that maybe if we'd
met in another place we'd become friends
or maybe we'd just fight you could
probably call it a connection of mutual
assistance between transient people
this event supposedly created the
transient co-op system we find in the
souls games and an elden ring where
anonymous players drop in help you
overcome a boss or defeat an invader or
invade you and then leave just as
quickly the anonymous aid of traditional
phantoms is good to create a certain
feeling for the player progressing
through the world but it also demands a
set of game mechanics that can be pretty
frustrating for friends just trying to
enjoy the game as a shared experience
basically the thing from software is
trying to achieve through their
multiplayer is great at delivering an
experience like the one miyazaki had in
his snow-stuck car but it is not
tailored to friends trying to
consistently co-opt together while there
is plenty of discussion that could be
had about fromsoft's intentions and game
design when it comes to multiplayer that
conversation really only has to be had
if we want from soft to change how
they're doing things
this mod doesn't demand that it just
gives players the opportunity to
experience the game in a different way
and at this point most people using the
mod are probably going to be people who
have already played through the game so
it isn't changing most people's first
experience with the story or the game as
a whole with that in mind i can't
recommend this mod highly enough to
anyone who has already played through
the game and would like some variation
or to players who would like to play
with their friends in a much more
seamless and fluid experience one
drawback to note is that because the
game is operating in offline mode
without connection to fromsoft servers
there are no invasions which is too bad
and even though there is additional
scaling for the enemy health and
difficulty it still has the opportunity
to turn pretty easy with multiple people
especially if everyone is riding around
on torrent or using op builds
fortunately the mod plays in offline and
is compatible with other mods so extra
difficulty can be added if needed
through that avenue you could also opt
to always keep pvp on for an extra
dosing of difficulty it's harder to spam
kill every enemy if you have to worry
about your attacks hitting your fellow
tarnished this is something i've been
having a lot of fun with so if it seems
like a fit for you i hope it can deliver
a similar experience if you're looking
for variety simple and straightforward
fun with friends or an easily repeatable
pvp opportunity like dark souls 3's
arenas this mod is a great option maybe
one day fromsoft will give us some elden
ring arenas in the coliseums maybe
through dlc but until then i'll be
pvping my friends this way where i only
have to wait for them to respawn out of
grace before we can fight again a much
more pleasant experience than
re-summoning and re-summoning and
re-summoning and as i also said there's
a good discussion to be had about what
kinds of changes should be made to the
actual multiplayer of elton ring but
i'll save that for another video this
one will just be a psa about a fun
alternative well i hope you've enjoyed
the video and be sure to subscribe if
you want to see more elden ring content
on lore game mechanics and more feel
free to talk in the comments about your
thoughts on fromsoft multiplayer whether
or not you've used and enjoyed this mod
and what other game mechanics and lore
you'd like to see discussed on my
channel you can also share what you
think about these videos that are more
centered on game mechanics than lore
most of my stuff is lore but branching
out into these game mechanic videos i'd
be interested to see what people have to
say i'll be away from making videos for
a little bit after this one comes out so
there will be some time before i release
another lore deep dive more time for all
of you to get your suggestions in the
comments in the meantime i have a few
videos like this one scheduled to
release somewhat weekly well thank you
for watching and i'll see you in the
next video peace
all right